>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON."
BRADDOCK IS BASICALLY EMPTY AT
THIS POINT.
ONLY 1700 PEOPLE LIVE THERE,
DOWN FROM A POPULATION OF MORE
THAN 18,000 DURING THE SECOND
WORLD WAR.
BRADDOCK IS NOW SO
UNDERPOPULATED THAT YOU CAN BUY
A FOUR-BEDROOM HOME THERE WITH A
TWO-CAR GARAGE IN THE MIDDLE OF
TOWN FOR $3,000.
DON'T BELIEVE IT.
CHECK IT OUT YOURSELF ON
REALTOR.COM.
SO, YOU KNOW, THE STORY, FOR
DECADES THE BIGGEST EMPLOYER IN
BRADDOCK WAS MANUFACTURING.
SOMETHING CALLED THE EDGAR
THOMPSON STEELWORKS.
IN FACT, ANDREW CARNEGIE.
THE PLANTS CLOSED, AND THERE WAS
UNEMPLOYMENT AND PEOPLE LEFT BY
THE THOUSANDS.
ONE MAN SAW AN OPPORTUNITY IN
BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA, NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE TOWN, BUT
FOR HIMSELF.
THAT MAN'S NAME WAS JOHN
FETORMAN.
HE WAS 35 YEARS OLD, NEVER IN
HIS LIFE HAD A REAL JOB.
GETTERMAN WAS NOT FROM BRADDOCK.
HE SPENT HIS LIFE GOING TO
BUSINESS SCHOOL, THEN TO HARVARD
FOR A SO-CALLED MASTERS OF
PUBLIC POLICY, WHICH FOR THE
UNINITIATED IS AN UTTERLY
MEANINGLESS DOCUMENT THAT YOU
PAY HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS TO GET IN ORDER TO TELL
PEOPLE THAT YOU WENT TO HARVARD.
IN FETTERMAN'S CASE, HIS DAD
PAID FOR IT, AND PAID FOR
EVERYTHING ELSE.
FOR A LONG STRETCH, DEEP INTO
HIS 40s, HIS INCOME CAME FROM
HIS FAMILY.
IN OTHER WORDS, JOHN FETTERMAN
WAS A CLASSIC TRUSTFORIAN.
IN 2005, A YEAR AFTER ARRIVING
IN BRADDOCK, FETTERMAN ANNOUNCED
HE WAS RUNNING FOR MAYOR.
AMAZINGLY, BOLDLY, GIVEN THAT HE
WAS A PROFESSIONAL STUDENT,
LIVING OFF HIS RICH FAMILY, JOHN
FETTERMAN DECIDED TO RUN AS A
BLUE COLLAR POPULIST.
THEY ASKED NO QUESTIONS.
THEY LOVED IT.
IN JOHN FETTERMAN, THE MEDIA SAW
THEMSELVES.
HE WAS JUST LIKE THEM.
FETTERMAN NARROWLY WON THE RACE,
AND THEN THE CAMPAIGN TO BOOST
JOHN FETTERMAN'S CAREER BEGAN IN
INEARNEST.
FETTERMAN WENT ON A NATIONAL
TOUR TO BRAG ABOUT HOW HE WAS
SINGLE-HANDEDLY SAVING A
BENIGHTED MILLION TOWN IN
WESTERN PENNSYLVANIA.
HE GAVE A TED TALK, ABOUT HOW HE
WAS RUNNING BRADDOCK USING THE
LESSONS HE LEARNED AT HARVARD.
IN 2011, HE WENT TO THE ASPEN
IDEAS FESTIVAL TO FURTHER BRAG.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID.
QUOTE, WE CREATED THE FIRST ART
GALLERY IN THE REGION WITH
ARTIST STUDIOS.
WE DID PUBLIC ART INSTALLATION.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CONSIDER ART
IT EXACTLY, BUT I CONSIDER
GROWING ORGANIC VEGETABLES AN
ART, AND THAT'S ATTRACTED
HOMESTEADING.
IT'S SO PERFECT.
HOMESTEADING, ORGANIC
VEGETABLES, ART INSTALLATION.
AND A HEAPING DOSE OF CLIMATE
THEOLOGY, ALL IMPORTED FROM
HARVARD.
HE IMPOSED CARBON CAPS ON
BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA.
HE SAID IT WOULD BRING MORE
MANUFACTURING JOBS BACK.
HE CALLED THIS INITIATIVE CARBON
CAPS EQUALS HARD HATS.
SO EXPENSIVE UNRELIABLE ENERGY
WILL MEAN MORE MANUFACTURING
JOB.
HOW NO ONE LAUGHED AT HIM.
JOHN FETTERMAN KEPT GOING.
IN A 2009 ADVERTISEMENT FOR
HIMSELF, HE PROMISED THAT,
QUOTE, WITH A SMART,
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE CARBON CAP
POLICY IN PLACE, COMMUNITIES
LIKE BRADDOCK CAN BEGIN TO BUILD
ITS MANUFACTURING AND
MIDDLE-CLASS BACK UP.
THIS WHOLE NOTION IF WE CAN
CONTINUE TO OPERATE AS WE HAVE
BEEN, AND IGNORE CLIMATE CHANGE,
IS LUDICROUS.
HA-HA-HA.
THEY LOVED IT AT THE ASPEN
INSTITUTE.
AND TO BE FAIR, JOHN FETTERMAN
DID NOT IGNORE CLIMATE CHANGE.
HE TALKED ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
ENDLESSLY.
HE MADE CLIMATE CHANGE THE
CENTERPIECE OF HIS
ADMINISTRATION IN BRADDOCK,
PENNSYLVANIA.
AS FOR ACTUALLY RUNNING THE TOWN
OR IMPROVING THE TOWN IN
BRADDOCK, HE WAS NOT INTERESTED.
NOT EVEN BILLINGS INTERESTED.
THAT'S PROVEABLE.
AS MAYOR, ACCORDING TO PUBLIC
RECORDS OBTAINED BY THE
WASHINGTON FREE BEACON,
FETTERMAN MISSED MORE THAN A
THIRD OF THE BOROUGH'S MONTHLY
MEETINGS, BECAUSE HE WAS OFF AT
THE ASPEN INSTITUTE.
IN HIS ENTIRE TENURE AS THE
MAYOR OF BRADDOCK, JOHN
FETTERMAN CAST A SINGLE VOTE, A
PROCEDURAL VOTE FOR BOROUGH
PRESIDENT.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
THIS IS OUR FAVORITE PART OF THE
STORY.
WHAT WERE THE RESULTS?
HOW DID BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA,
FAIR UNDER THE LEADERSHIP OF
JOHN FETTERMAN?
WE WANT TO BE AS FAIR AND
OBJECTIVE AS WE CAN BE.
UNDER HIS TENURE, AS MAYOR OF
BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA, THE SEAS
DID NOT RISE.
THAT'S TRUE.
BRADDOCK IS STILL ON DRY LAND.
OF COURSE IT'S FAR FROM THE
OCEAN, BUT IT'S STILL DRY.
SO HIS CLIMATE POLICY WORKED.
HE CAN BE PROUD OF THAT, BUT THE
POPULATION IS AT THE LOWEST
LEVEL EVER RECORDED.
THE MEDIAN INCOME IN BRADDOCK,
PENNSYLVANIA, IS $14,000 A YEAR.
MORE THAN A THIRD OF HOUSEHOLDS
IN BRADDOCK LIVE BELOW THE
POVERTY LINE.
BRADDOCK, BY THE WAY, HAS ONE OF
THE HIGHEST CRIME RATES IN THE
STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA.
IN 2018, SHORTLY AFTER FETTERMAN
LEFT OFFICE, BRADDOCK'S PER
CAPITA MURDER RATE WAS HIGHER
THAN IT IS IN SOME OF THE MOST
DANGEROUS COUNTRIES IN THE
WORLD.
HONDURAS AND BELIZE ARE SAFER
THAN BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA.
SO THAT'S A FAILURE.
AND IN A FUNCTIONING SYSTEM, A
RECORD LIKE THIS WOULD HAVE
DISQUALIFIED JOHN FETTERMAN FROM
EVER RUNNING FOR ANYTHING AGAIN.
HE FAILED DEMONSTRABLY AS A
LEADER.
A HIGHER MURDER RATE THAN
HONDURAS AND LOWEST POPULATION
EVER RECORDED.
SORRY, CLIMATE CHANGE DIDN'T
IMPROVE THE TOWN.
IN A FAIR SYSTEM, A SYSTEM THAT
CARED ABOUT ACHIEVEMENT, JOHN
FETTERMAN WOULD BE LEAVING
POLITICS ON THE EXPRESS TRAIN
AND MOVING ON TO SOMETHING LIKE
INTERPRETIVE DANCE.
TRY THAT.
MAYBE GET HIS DAD TO PAY FOR SKI
LESSONS AND MOVE TO ASPEN.
OR SOMETHING.
WE DON'T HAVE A FUNCTIONING
MERITOCRACY, MUCH LESS A
FUNCTIONING POLITICAL SYSTEM.
WE HAVE A VERY BROKEN ONE.
HAVING WRECKED BRADDOCK, HE
BECAME LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR, AND
NOW PLANS TO RUN FOR THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
WHAT'S HE GOING TO DO HE GETS
THERE?
HIS IDEA IS TO MAKE THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY MUCH MORE LIKE BRADDOCK
WITH HIGHER CRIME RATES.
WE'RE NOT MAKING THAT UP.
HERE HE IS, JUNE FETTERMAN, IN
2020, AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR,
FANTIZEING ABOUT GIVING AMNESTY
TO THOUSANDS OF VIOLENT
CRIMINALS, INCLUDING MURDERERS.
>> IF YOU HAD A MAGIC WAND,
COULD WAVE IT, FIX ONE THING,
WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> LIFE WITHOUT PAROLE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
WE COULD SAVE BILLIONS IN
REVENUE LONG TERM, SAVE
THOUSANDS OF LIVES, AND NOT MAKE
ANYONE ELSE LESS SAFE.
AND ALSO EXPUNGE AS MANY
PERMANENT RECORDS OF PEOPLE
LIVING THEIR BEST LIVES, PAYING
WELL BEYOND WHEN THEY SHOULD
HAVE FOR A CHARGE THAT THEY
THOUGHT, YOU KNOW, 10, 15, 20
YEARS AGO.
>> Tucker: SO IN HUGE PARTS OF
PENNSYLVANIA, WHICH IS A BIG
STATE, REAL STATE, FILLED WITH
REALLY NICE PEOPLE, AN ECONOMIC
POWERHOUSE FOR MORE THAN A
HUNDRED YEARS, IN HUGE PARTS OF
THAT STATE, THERE ARE NO JOBS.
THERE'S POVERTY.
THERE'S HOPELESSNESS.
THERE ARE HUGE NUMBERS OF DRUG
O.D.s.
THAT STATE HAS BEEN DEVASTATED
BY OPIODED, BY FENTANYL.
BUT JOHN FETTERMAN, IF HE COULD
MAKE ONE CHANGE TO THE STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA, HE'D LET THE
MURDERERS OUT.
RIGHT.
THAT'S WHO HE CARES ABOUT.
SO IN PENNSYLVANIA, TYPICALLY IF
YOU COMMIT MURDER YOU GET LIFE
IN PRISON, AS YOU SHOULD.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO KILL PEOPLE.
FETTERMAN WOULD CHANGE THAT.
HE'D HIKE YOU OUT OF JAIL AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
NO ACTUAL POPPIST OR WORKING
CLASS PERSON TALKS LIKE THIS,
WORRIES ABOUT PUNISHING
MURDERERS TOO MUCH.
MAYBE IF YOU ACHIEVE THE FIRST
115 THINGS ON YOUR TO-DO LIST,
YOU'D WORRY IF MURDERERS WERE
SERVING TOO MUCH TIME IN MIGHT
PRISON,AFTER YOU GOT PEOPLE JOBR
YOU CONVINCED PEOPLE TO STAY IN
THE STATE WHERE THEY WERE BORN,
AFTER YOU FIXED THE FACT THAT
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE DYING OF
DRUG O.D.s.
ONLY RICH KIDS THINK LIKE THAT.
ONLY WORKING MAN WEARS A HOODY
TO A POLITICAL EVENT.
ALL YOUR STUPID FAKE TATTOOS.
IT'S A COSTUME OF COURSE.
DUH.
IT'S NOT REAL.
JOHN FETTERMAN INSPIRED BY HIS
TIME AT HARVARD AND THE ASPEN
INSTITUTE WOULD LIKE TO FREE A
THIRD OF THE PRISON POPULATION
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT'S JUST FOR STARTERS.
WATCH.
>> I WAS ON A PANEL WITH
SECRETARY WETZEL EARLIER BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC HIT, AND HE SAID
SOMETHING REMARKABLE THAT I
AGREE WITH.
HE SAID, WE COULD REDUCE OUR
PRISON POPULATION BY A THIRD AND
NOT MAKE ANYONE LESS SAFE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THAT'S A PROFOUND STATEMENT.
>> Tucker: IT'S NOT A PROFOUND
STATEMENT.
IT'S ABSURD.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
OH, IT'S A PROFOUND STATEMENT.
WHERE DO YOU LEARN TO TALK LIKE
THIS, SAYS THE GUY WHO WEARS A
HOODY.
YOU WRECKED THE TOWN YOU RAN,
DIDN'T SHOW UP AT COUNCIL
MEETINGS.
LET THE MURDERERS OUT.
WE'LL HAVE A SAFER SOCIETY WHEN
WE LET THE INSCOURGIBLE VIOLENT
RUN AMONGST IT.
HE MADE BRADDOCK, PENNSYLVANIA,
MORE VIOLENT THAN HONDURAS.
IT'S TO CHANGE THE STATE FOREVER
FOR HIS OWN POLITICAL BENEFIT.
THE POINT IS TO FLOOD THE STATE
OF PENNSYLVANIA WITH BRAND-NEW
VOTERS, ALL OF THEM LOYAL TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MORE VOTER FRAUD, PLEASE.
FETTERMAN HAS BEEN IN LOCKSTEP
WITH THE LEADERS OF HIS PARTY ON
THAT QUESTION FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING.
THAT'S WHY HE WOULD LIKE TO GET
RID OF ALL BARRIERS TO VOTER
FRAUD, INCLUDING AND ESPECIALLY
VOTER ID, AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
>> IN MY OWN STATE, THEY ARE
GOING TO PASS, ATTEMPT TO PASS,
A CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT,
MAKING SURE THAT UNIVERSAL
VOTING ID FOR EVERY TIME YOU
VOTE, NOT JUST WHEN YOU SIGN UP
TO VOTE, BUT EVERY TIME YOU
VOTE, BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTAND
THAT AT ANY GIVEN TIME THERE'S
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
PENNSYLVANIANS WHO TYPICALLY ARE
ON THE -- ARE ON THE POORER
SIDE, AND ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR,
THAT ARE LESS LIKELY TO HAVE
THEIR ID AT ANY ONE GIVEN TIME.
>> Tucker: SO POOR PEOPLE DON'T
HAVE IDs?
REALLY?
'CAUSE EVERYONE WHO LIVES IN OUR
SOCIETY OVER THE AGE OF 18 HAS A
GOVERNMENT-ISSUED ID, BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T LIVE HERE OTHERWISE,
AND CAN'T COLLECT GOVERNMENT
BENEFITS WITHOUT ONE.
CAN'T DO ANYTHING WITHOUT ONE.
THAT'S A LIE.
HE'S AFFIRMATIVELY ABETTING
VOTER FRAUD.
THE CLIPS WE JUST PLAYED WERE
JUNE FETTERMAN SPEAKING BEFORE
HE HAD -- AND WE SAY WITH NO
GLEE, BUT WITH DEEP SYMPATHY --
A MASSIVE STROKE.
HIS CAMPAIGN SAYS THE STROKE
OCCURRED SHORTLY BEFORE HE WON
THE DEMOCRATIC STATE PRIMARY IN
MAY.
WHENEVER IT HAPPENED, OR
WHATEVER CAUSED IT, THE STROKE
HAS BEEN PROFOUND, RENDERED
FETTERMAN UNABLE TO SPEAKKO
COHERENTLY.
WE DON'T SAY IT MEAN, BUT IT'S
ABOUT THE COUNTRY HE HOPES TO
CONTROL IF ELECTED TO THE UNITED
STATES SENATE.
IT'S BAD.
IT'S REALLY BAD.
HERE HE WAS CAMPAIGNING RECENTLY
IN PITTSBURGH, FOR EXAMPLE.
>> JUST EARLIER TODAY I WAS SO
PROUD TO MARCH WITH YOU IN
DOWNTOWN PITTSBURGH, LABOR
DAY -- HAPPY LABOR DAY.
SEND ME TO WASHINGTON, D.C. TO
SEND -- SO I CAN WORK WITH
SENATOR CASEY, AND I CAN
CHAMPION THE UNION WAY OF LIFE
IN JERSEY -- EXCUSE ME -- IN
D.C.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S AN HONOR.
I LIVE EIGHT MINUTES AWAY FROM
HERE.
WHEN I LEAVE TONIGHT, I GOT
THREE MILES AWAY, DR. OZ, IN HIS
MANSION IN NEW JERSEY, YOU'VE
GOT A FRIEND, AND YOU HAVE AN
ALLY.
SEND ME TO WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Tucker: YOU KNOW, IT'S NOT
EVEN WORTH MAKING FUN OF.
IT'S SAD.
BUT WHEN COGNITION GOES, WHEN
THE ABILITY TO THINK CLEARLY
DISAPPEARS, AND IN HIS CASE IT
OBVIOUSLY HAS, WHAT'S LEFT?
THE TALKING POINTS.
THAT'S ALL THAT REMAINS.
THAT'S ALL HE HAS.
THE TALKING POINTS.
THE UNION WAY OF LIFE.
THIS KID LIVED OFF HIS PARENTS
UNTIL HE WAS IN HIS MID 40s.
HE'S NEVER BEEN IN A UNION.
WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT, YOU
FRAUD.
NOT SURPRISINGLY FETTERMAN HAS
REFUSED, UP UNTIL TODAY, TO
SCHEDULE A DEBATE WITH HIS
OPPONENT, DR. OZ.
JUST HOURS AGO HE ANNOUNCED HE'S
WILLING TO DEBATE.
NO DETAILS ARE FORTHCOMING.
SOMETIME IN MID-OCTOBER.
OF COURSE, WHEN THE EARLY VOTING
HAS ALREADY BEEN WELL IN
PROGRESS.
IT'S STARTING NOW, BY THE WAY,
THE EARLY VOTING IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
SO IF YOU DELAY THE DEBATE TO
RIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION IT'S
IRRELEVANT, BECAUSE PEOPLE HAVE
ALREADY VOTED.
ONLY DEMOCRATS SEEM TO
UNDERSTAND THIS.
HE DOESN'T EVEN TALK TO THE
MEDIA AT THIS POINT, BECAUSE HE
CAN'T.
IN SOME CASES, HERE'S ONE, HIS
STAFFERS WON'T LET HIM ANSWER
QUESTIONS THAT HE'S POSED.
WATCH THIS.
>> HEY, JOHN, ARE YOU AFRAID TO
DEBATE DR. OZ?
ARE YOU AFRAID TO DEBATE DR. OZ?
>> THANK YOU, JOHN.
>> ARE YOU GOING TO DEBATE HIM?
HE'S OFFERED YOU FIVE DEBATES.
ARE YOU GOING TO DEBATE HIM?
>> Tucker: HIS HOODY AND
FRAUDULENT TATTOOS.
I MEAN, HONESTLY, THIS IS LIKE
THE BARISTA IN BROOKLYN DRESSING
LIKE A LUMBERJACK PLEASE, YOU
FAKE.
THE GUY CAN'T EVEN TALK.
JOHN FETTERMAN, A CANDIDATE FOR
THE U.S. SENATE CANNOT SPEAK.
WATCH.
>> MEMBERS OF THE UNITED STEEL
WORKERS TUESDAY, FETTERMAN WAS
ON MESSAGE, BUT OFTEN HALTING IN
HIS SPEECH, AND OCCASIONALLY
DROPPED WORDS MID-SENTENCE.
>> BEING ANTI-UNION IS
ANTI-AMERICAN.
WHAT IS WRONG WITH DEMANDING FOR
AN EASY, SAFE KIND OF THEIR
INCOME, A PATH TO A SAFE PLACE
FOR THEM TO WIN -- OR EXCUSE
ME -- TO WORK.
>> FETTERMAN DECLINED TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS FROM CNN AND OTHER
REPORTERS AT THE EVENT.
>> Tucker: SO WE COULD GO ON AND
ON AND PLAY YOU MORE TAPE, BUT
IT'S JUST AWFUL.
NOBODY WANTS TO WATCH IT.
WE WANT TO MAKE THE POINT, THIS
GUY IS COMPLETELY REPAIRED.
THAT'S NOT A REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINT.
IT'S COMPLETELY REAL.
SO THINK ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS.
THE DEMOCRATIC APPARENT HAS NOT
REPLACED HIM.
THIS HAS BEEN GOING ON SINCE HE
GOT THE NOMINATION, BUT HE'S
STILL IN THE RACE.
THAT'S SHOCKING AND IT'S
INSULTING, NOT SIMPLY TO VOTERS
IN PENNSYLVANIA, BUT TO THE REST
OF US, BECAUSE IF ELECTED WE'LL
HAVE TO LIVE UNDER HIS RULE, BUT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY PREFERS IT
THAT WAY.
THEY DID IT WITH BIDEN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO IT AGAIN
WITH FETTERMAN.
RUN A WAX DUMMY FOR OFFICE.
PEOPLE WHO CAN'T COMPLETE
COMPLETE SENTENCES CAN'T TALK.
FETTERMAN AND BIDEN ARE MUCH
EASIER TO CONTROL.
SO ON THE ONE OCCASION FETTERMAN
HAS BEEN ASKED DIRECTLY ABOUT
THIS, WAIT A SECOND, YOU'RE
COGNITIVELY IMPAIRED.
HOW DID HE RESPOND?
IF YOU'VE GOT A PROBLEM WITH A
BRAIN-DAMAGED SENATOR, YOU'RE A
BIGOT.
WATCH THIS.
>> CAN YOU EVEN IMAGINE, IF YOU
HAVE A DOCTOR MOCKING YOUR
ILLNESS, RIDICULING THAT?
WELL, HERE WE ARE.
HERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT
DR. OZ MAY HAVE REALLY LOST HIS
WAY IF YOU'RE GOING TO MAKE FUN
OF SOMEBODY THAT HAD A STROKE.
>> Tucker: OH, MAKING FUN OF
PEOPLE.
HOW DARE YOU DO THAT.
HE'S DISABLED.
SHUT UP.
ACCEPT IT.
HOW DARE YOU ACKNOWLEDGE THE
OBVIOUS.
YOU HAVE NO RIGHT.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT JOHN
FETTERMAN'S PERSONAL JOURNEY.
SO YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO ASK,
WELL, HOW DOES THIS AFFECT ME,
IF THAT GUY CAN'T THINK CLEARLY
IS ELECTED TO THE UNITED STATES
SENATE?
THAT'S IMPLIGHT.
THEY DO IT ON SO MANY ISSUES.
THEY'RE DOING IT WITH HIM.
IT WORKS.
MOST PEOPLE JUST SHUT UP.
IT'S CONSIDERED COMPLETELY OUT
OF BOUNDS TO MENTION THE FACT
THAT JOHN FETTERMAN IS
COMPLETELY INCAPABLE OF
REPRESENTING PENNSYLVANIA IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE.
AS WE SAID, THAT FACT -- AND IT
IS A FACT -- IS FINE WITH THE
PEOPLE WHO RUN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
THEY JUST WANT THE POWER.
THE REST OF US SHOULD BE VERY
WORRIED BY THIS.
IF THEY CAN GET THIS GUY ELECTED
STATEWIDE IN THIS
ASSASSINATION'S FIFTH LARGEST
STATE, THIS GUY, AN INCOMPETENT
HUSK, WITH INCREDIBLY STUPID AND
TOTALLY PROVEABLE DESTRUCTIVE
IDEAS, A MAN WITH NO RECORD OF
ACHIEVEMENT AT ALL, A MAN WITH A
LONG LIST OF DOCUMENTED
FAILURES, A MAN WHO, BY THE WAY,
CANNOT THINK CLEARLY, IF THEY
CAN DO THAT, THEY CAN